I'm looking for a man that can make me  feel safe and protected and somebody  that I can trust Ben Higgins broke up  with Jojo Fletcher on TV for all to see  I love you I found it with you but I  found it with somebody else more now  Fletcher tells GMA she doesn't  communicate with Ben anymore and that on  her season of The Bachelorette she's  looking for something safe filming is  well underway and things seem to be  heating up I'm actually feeling feelings  which I didn't expect so early on  Bachelorette executive producer Mike  Fleiss has been tweeting up a storm  about the season so far  saying the crew is calling it the most  dramatic ever apparently there has  already been a near fistfight